in this competitive world getting a
dream job is very important and
necessary
when students graduate from their
academy they need a platform to showcase
their talent and gain experience in the
industry
for which getting placed in a company is
very important so here's a video by
simply learn fully dedicated to how to
prepare for off-campus placement stick
to the end of this video to get your new
job faster and with ease
to crack an off-campus placement you can
follow a few easy steps
but before we move on please subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
icon to never miss an update from
simplylearn
now coming back to the topic let's
understand the first step you must
follow to crack the interview how do you
prepare for the off-campus job
while you are preparing for any campus
or off-campus training remember to
follow these three steps
the first step is to focus on your
skills when we are talking about skills
there are two types soft skills and hard
skills
soft skills are the features and
personality traits of you and your
behavior like communication skills time
management etc
talking about hard skills core
programming and technical skills comes
under hard skills which differ from role
to role
most commonly asked for hard skills are
data structure and algorithm in-trend
programming languages java python etc
basic operating system knowledge etc
this type of hard skills will set your
potential
and at last focus on any additional
skills that you have and feel are needed
the next step is to build a strong
resume that shows all the essential
details about you as a professional
briefly and clearly
remember to keep your resume short and
direct
your resume and content will set your
potential for the role and the company
when applying for an off-campus
placement a resume is one of the most
important factors to help you achieve
your end goal
the final phase in preparing for
off-campus placement is referring to
interview videos
these videos will help you to know the
most frequently asked questions and
crack the interview of that company
you can check out our simply learn
youtube channel to access some of these
videos which include various recruitment
processes for various companies and some
interview questions that can help you
land your dream job
after conceptual preparation you must
get ready for the interview process
the interview process differs for each
company in general they will keep three
to four rounds of the interview like
aptitude technical group discussion and
hr the aptitude round will have some
basic mathematical questions
the technical round will have some
technical questions and basic programs
you may have more than one technical
round based on the company
some companies hold group discussions to
check the communication skill of the
candidate
you must be able to talk for five to six
minutes on the given topic
the last process will be the hr round
which is common for every company
here you will be asked general questions
like why did you choose our company what
are your strengths and weaknesses
where do you see yourself after three to
four years and many more
once you complete all these rounds you
will be selected for that interview
process
this final round is to check whether you
are a cultural fit for the company or
not
once you are fully prepared for the
interview the next step is to apply for
an off-campus job
while applying for any job manually you
can use some well-known portals like
angel list why combinator jobs
linkedin
now cree
the second step is to get a reference
linkedin is one of the finest channels
that you can find references
linkedin is the biggest professional
networking platform globally and helps
establish relationships with various
industries and employees
first you must create a linkedin account
upload your updated resume and make a
strong profile
and then search for any company profile
and follow them on linkedin
make a connection with who is working in
your desired industry
look for some connections from your
college or university and follow them
and after this you can ask them to refer
you to their company for any of your
desired positions
with this you can get a reference for
any job off-campus you can also
participate in some of the contests on
hacker earth and hacker rank where the
winner or the good performers are
provided with decent job opportunities
with this we come to the end of this
session we saw the two best ways to
prepare for off-campus placements so
which company are you applying for and
for which role let us know in the
comments below we wish you the best of
luck for your interviews i hope this
session was interesting and informative
please like the video and share it with
your friends
for more such videos you can visit our
simply learn youtube channel
[Music]